[Music]
from one of the greatest living
directors comes one of the greatest MCU
movies ever made yeah that's right the
mafia Cinematic Universe and what do you
think I'm talking about Spider-Man over
here come on forget about it oh
Good Fellas
is throwing a tank top slip on a pinky
ring and crack open a carton of cigs
because you are about to enter the
Glamorous world of the Italian mob it's
got everything fast bread fast bread I
didn't have to wait in line at the
bakery anymore cool nicknames there was
Pete the killer Mickey eyes and Jimmy
two times I'm gonna go get the papers
get the papers and a dozen of your best
middle-aged guy friends for smooching on
[Music]
hey come here
um
[Music]
wow yeah it feels so good to be a
gangster
Mama Mia that's mommy around a little oh
enjoy a milestone in representation for
sweaty guys who are ugly and sexy at the
same time like Ray Liotta's Henry Hill
an outsider who provides the movie's
voice over if we wanted something we
just took it and it's laugh track
[Laughter]
money for the commercial
you don't got my money it's funny
because it's someone else's pain follow
along on his Rico themed master class as
he takes you from Small Time park to
Professor of hudanomics until he's
brought down by a Joe pesci-sized
mountain of cocaine oh well at least he
learned his lesson get to live the rest
of my life like a schnook at least he
regrets his choices it was a glorious
time at least he was slightly more
willing to clean up other people's blood
that was the first time I'd ever seen
anyone shot
don't get Italian
see good fella but Henry's not the only
Mook in this mookie before he was the
Irishman Robert De Niro was this Irish
Man Jimmy Conway and before Scorsese
could de-age that mug they just said he
was 28 and we all went with it he could
have been more than 28 or 29 at the time
then there's Joe Pesci's Tommy DeVito
who combines the body of Danny DeVito
with the Berserker rage of Wolverine
make it happen feige Lorraine Bronco
shines as Karen Hill whose care inside
only comes out when her husband side
chick is involved sister superintendent
I want you to know sir that you have a
living otherwise she's one of the
all-time greats at ignoring crimes I
didn't think there was anything strange
in any of this
none of it seemed like crimes and
supporting them all is a legendary cast
of hey I know that guys like that guy
that guy and that guy if you're
wondering where you know half the bad
guy's from It's The Sopranos it's always
The Sopranos
[Music]
[Music]
oh
it happens strap in for a film packed
with great characters incredible
cinematography and more quotable lines
for dads than a classic SNL box set a
funny how I mean funny like I'm a clown
I am usually to the point where you
won't really care there isn't a plot
just two and a half hours of crimes and
Vibes but if you dig a Little Deeper you
find the story of a resilient kid who
survives a tough New York childhood only
to take dangerous amounts of drugs get a
new suit join a powerful organization
and do whatever it takes to protect the
people he cares about the most on our
own forget everybody else
you know why oh I could do this all day
away capisce on my mother's grave
they're right there is America's ass
so suit up for a fill with more
headshots than a Call of Duty death
match
[Music]
and more slurs then well also that just
stole my truck
I have some you know who goes to jail
stick up man that's right cigarette as
this fast talking mobster draws the
audience in seducing you into his evil
World Until you realize just like Henry
that you're trapped paranoid and [ __ ]
six ways from Sunday in another Scorsese
film that glorifies violence and toxic
masculinity as long as you ignore the
subtext trust the unreliable narrator
and don't watch the last 40 minutes but
hey there's plenty of entertainment out
there for everyone perhaps you prefer
something simpler like a cartoon when am
I a played a dry stick but me here too
amuse you starring
the way do crime whack-a-mole die cousin
Vinnie Broncos Modern Life Boss Hogg
hell to pay unhappy feet two Coke girls
oh man I shot Stacks in the face and the
most in the movie until Scorsese beat
his own record with casino and Wolf of
Wall Street how the [ __ ] am I funny what
the [ __ ]
white Menace to Society
[Music]
and it's kind of weird the same year
this came out they made another movie
about the same mobster starring Steve
Martin
honestly Goodfellas is a classic but
it's seriously lacking merengue
as far back as I could remember I always
wanted to be a gangster
Knuckles are red Sonics are blue I know
the way and you will know too
you spin me right round baby right round